分享一条操極干脱
作为2.26年送给大家的新年礼物
普通人如何通过三个方法
十操的方法 完成了一期
这三个方法全部来自真善礼
就是我们2.26
江湖说现象年会第一天
上午的真善礼
所以大家可以暗途所谓找到具体的实施细节
首先 第一步向数据的负质
这种来自于我们李公子的分享
它是在2021年二年的关注度
然后它是向数据负质的股
然后现在年入大概很轻松
年入七倍数
这个打开找到它的账号
就很多说 为什么这么不要脸
就负质你
因为我好负质
就是好多人
你是很难负质的 比如说我们负质调不赐
负质马赐 质马云这个很难负质
但是你负质你的同事
负质你的隔壁的铃鱼
这个就比较好负质
所以我们负质方法什么呢
是找一个我们可以够的找的人
然后给大家分享他具体的方法
首先第一部分
就是找到以后你认为可以负质的人
它在某个领域取得的一个成绩
但注意不是看
不要计希望你看他一条两条内容和文章
让你就可以获得获得成绩
而是把他过去所有的相关的思量
比如说他的工作号
他的视频 他的书记 全部找出来
但注意不是去学习所有的内容
而是学习他重复的内容
因为重复的内容
才是他真正的内容
那是他举一反散的
所以把所有内容找出来以后
然后去找他们
让重复的反复提到的东西
那个才是最重要的东西
东西这是第一步
第二步的话
就是把那个重复的内容开了会晤晤
他朋友的方法的人
比如说关键之间 化一个空
然后把它放在空下来
然后找到关键之间
然后支持点之间的联系
也就是他们真的用关系
形成那个框架
注意
我们真正要负质负质的别人的框架
比如说你要拍短视频
其实你负质不是别人的内容
你把别人的内容打算
有没有用那都是别人的
你要负质质的框架
比如说他是怎么开头的
他的结果怎么做的
然后他是怎么表达的
用别人的结果做自己的内容
所以最好的方法是
负质别人的框架和系统
那李宫子负质的是我的系统
所以他会把我过去的
重复的关键之间
全部滑出来
然后找到关键之间
成为之间的那个联系
就形成了框架
然后第三个部分的话
针对某一个具体的关键之间
然后他通过话图的方式
然后看看
包括他表达出来
比如说排程短这个样
或者将给别人听
或者写成文字
注意你喜也不出来
你表达出来
就是不知道
我说你看的话你很容易
当你表达出来
给别人讲明卖
对吧
然后你这个时候
就是不明白
就是不理解
你要重新学习
对四个部分是关键的一个部分
去做项目
在真正的项目中去去吃操
然后实际操作用
把这个知识带入简单
然后这个时候才能
才是真正的学义之中
这是他那天分享的四个部分
那我当时跟大家说
要项目书记的腐质
为什么要腐质
很有时候都要去重新
注意过
我们很多人是不是和重新的
就好像说
你如果不会一家一
等一二的话
那你就不要去做媒体
所以普通人一开始
就是去项目书记的腐质
而不是去重新的
怎么腐质的
理工的方法
可以给大家一个帮助
我们大家可以看一些
相关的聚得细节
就是第一个部分
像素质的腐质
第二个部分
像小强一样去做实验
就像小强一样去玩强
这个案例来自于三三
这个好多的话
就都知道了
三三是四岁的时候
开始做这个事情的
他们大概是做外卖的
就是做外卖
因为家里亲戚就有人做外卖出事
他一次做外卖的时候
做宋外卖的时候的话
好像是石主鱼
我记得好像石主鱼
然后就差一点就出事
当石主真的很难受
后来的话
他啥到我的时候
我当时提到一个关键点
我说
其实普通人
最普通人来说
自媒体是普通人
翻身的一个最好的路径
他当时就线了
干嘛呢
就开始买黄豆
他当时客厅
客厅
应该是租的房子
客厅特别是好
他怎么办呢
他就在错锁里
大家可以去找
他在错锁里直播
就是把那个
满头
满头盖就当作椅子
然后在错锁里直播
所以他一开始的那个直播
用了那个嫁子
就是不快嫌呢
什么灯光
什么收音社会就没有
就在错锁里
我们拿过五块钱的嫁子
这个手机
就拿豆子就开始
就开始直播了
第一步什么是用特别简单的
这个成本就开始去做了
短日离吗
也没有什么成本
普通人的时间是不是简单
所以机会没什么成本
然后去去尝试
所以用最低的可能性去做车事
第二部分就是
暴力事号
什么意思呢
他说他每天一不合就是
六个到十五小时
就后来开始
散了平的开始做物化
我这个不鼓励
但是我为什么说这件事情呢
就是我真的希望那些
没事老翔的有确定性
我告诉该怎么做的时候去做
或者是什么呢
干了两天
每天
看到二十十分钟
然后就抱怨自己
为什么没有成人
我觉得她的爱
过时可能对应有帮助
为什么
因为她是初重生
很多东西都不懂
所以怎么办
她就把市场拉上
通过初手的似书
通过市场提升自己的概率
好的话呢
不断的跌带
不断的改进
然后提升自己的命中
你的成功
可能等于你到命中
就是你单侧的质量
成为一出手的似书
穿的市场
这说我们说的第二部分
第三个部分的话呢
就是她不还丢脸
她说她在
吃活的时候
什么都不会
怎么划窗
真的都不会
都是别人一边做一边
一边搞扶她
但是恰恰是这样的话
就是她她是真实的
很多东西不会
别人问她
她确实她也知道不会
她也告诉别人
不会
但是这个这样确实真实的
然后她现在还带着
好像一百多人
带了好多一百多人
开始就是
扶着她的那个那个路径
我记得在在我们年会的时候
又老婆就问她
说你文化又不高
你怎么还给别人讲东西呢
我就这恰恰恰是她
她真正可以做的事情
因为她本身
没有给大学别人
大学什么
给博士给教授样
她讲得昨天的事情
对吧
因为她真的单场做到
一晚了
我记得这个很老婆
就有印象
就年会的航中
年会的时候
她背着不过起
背着红洞
如果我们那个
年会有完了
和晚上直播
一直直播
单场买了一万
一场买了一万
然后约入期万
对吧
作为她来说
她可以讲给昨天的事情
和她一样的
没有文化的
没有背景
不会的一路走过来的人
她到底是怎么做的
对吧
我觉得
走过的门方法
对吧
分享给别人
这是第二个部分
像小强一样
搬强
然后第三个部分是
勾点自材
这个案例来自于逆风
逆风的话
很年轻
她应该是
212年关注我
当时就口罩的时候
她回到国内
坐那个什么
日于到时
越新六千
扣完了以后
最后就四千回家了
现在的话
去年的话
英年的公司
营有合
是1500万
1000万
我那间来的时候
好多人都唯一的
我回来一看
应该是她
好多人唯一的她
给她分享
她讲了什么呢
就是她是怎么做的
首先第一个部分
她是日于老师的时候
那时候
她刷到我的短视频
然后每天刷每天
说她说她得到
最大的两个
两个感受
一个是租动学习
一个是租动工作
啥意思
就好多人工作
就是模样工
就是好多人下班了
我拿工作
我不得你好感
但他呢
就是提升自己的技能
注意这就好很多
你去打工的时候
你真正要得到的
不是新水
是什么是技能
我再说一遍
你去打工的时候
你真正得到的
不是新水
而是技能
所以她当时主动学习
就是把这个技能
学合手
第二块
是转着点
就是什么呢
就是技能产品化
她怎么做的呢
实际上是她在主动学习
所以她不除了自己的本人工作
台具学什么營焦
学管理
所以她后来开始慢慢升级的
她自己负责了一个项目
负责一个项目
然后这个项目的话
就是给公司带着很多的令人
结果
就有人
就是想要背后那个系统
的客家背后的系统
而那个系统那个客家就
她自己欧监子
所以那个时候
她就把一个技能
做了她的穿品
那么我们说
购建资产
就是在打工的时候
你要学会去购建资产
因为你带新穿越呀
是不是
购建资产
怎么就表示她是个资产
各位三件事
第一件事听
这个事和平台无关
就是很多的努力
很多人被死得闹
你其实不是
是因为你在那个平台上
所以你购建那个东西
脱利的那个平台
是不是别人还会去工作
对吧
第二件事情的话
就是你要你过脱利时间的限制
就是这个事先
还需要脱大量的时间
那是不行的
脱大量的时间是不行的
第三件事情是什么的
就是你要不要在场
你不在场
这个事情仍然可行
对吧
我觉得是OK的
所以大家在做的工作
一定要主动的去
学习
然后怎么可能变成
基本上就谁的问题
什么问题
我时候能解决
所以各位
好好思考一下
普通人尼西的三部
第一部分是
像数据的富士
有一开始我们不是和床心的
你不会一家一
等一二
就不要去做一份
所以怎么就富士
找一份
你能够的找个人
然后看他那种
重複的东西
那个才是在床讲
负质他的
床讲负质的系统
而不是所谓的
表面的这个内容
然后
尽肯定会知道床是
把这个内容不要出来
如果你表达出来
就不会
一定在项目中去使用这样的一个
去去使用这样的这个
只是才是学义之用
所以第一部分
不是床心
而是项目书记的富士
你的体点
第二部分是行动
一定要像小强一样
完成
一开始
不要等什么东西都准备好了
这个世界是充满
不确定性的
用最小的充满
最可能的
只要能做
就开始去床市
只要成本足够低
那你就可以
认识错
错了有无所谓
因为成本足够低吧
对吧
然后一定要学会
就会用暴力垃圾
有的时候是需要刻意地去联系的
因为我们的成功
当于你单辞的
这两场义出手的事素
所以认识没有太多
基础的人
你认应该提升你出手的
次数或者是上
同时这个功能
不得的提升的能力
不要总想到
把完美的一面
就是穿这个一边
就是你丢的一面
反而会有真实性
而且你丢的一面
越过来之后
被人可以看到
原来你是这么一步一步一步一步一步
你的抗案
你在经验
可以获得别人的信任
同时对别人一有帮助
注意
你哪怕很猜
也不要去
你分享给昨天的司机的
然后第三个部分
在功能公众
一定要学会
购天子的资产
是注动学习做动工作
然后
提升自己的技能
什么事情呢
就是这个事情
解决谁的什么问题
过是否可以
那么解决
这就是你的标准
你打工
真的不是信水
而是能力
那么在下一步
就是把能力产品化
就是你可以脱离世界
脱离在场
脱离平台
你也能脱离世界
也能够获得收益
这就是我们购天子产
所以购一三步第一
一开始项速机的负质
第二
在习目找一下小强一样
完成
第三
随时随地购天自己的资产
新年快乐